good morning miss moss or i should say
good afternoon your time your time uh my
name is ben chu from the firm of brown
rudnick
would you please state your full name
for the record
kate smuss
miss moss where do you reside
london england
from where are you testifying today miss
moss
i'm gloucestershire england
miss moss do you know johnny depp
yes i do
how do you know mr depp
i had a relationship with him
uh did there come a time when you and mr
depp had a romantic relationship
yes
for how long miss moss were you and mr
depp a romantic couple
from 1993
to
1994 to 1998.
miss moss did there come a time when you
uh while you and mr depp were a couple
that the two of you took a vacation
together
to the golden eye resort in jamaica
yes
what if anything happened when you were
in jamaica with mr depp
i
um
we were leaving the room
and johnny left the room before i did
and there had been a rainstorm
and
as i left the room i slid down the
stairs
and i hurt my back
how did you
i apologize miss miles please continue
and i screamed because i was in
because i didn't know what happened to
me and i was in pain and
he came
running back to help me
and carried me to my room and
got me medical attention
did mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs
miss moss have you ever before today
testified in any kind of court
proceeding
no i have never why did you decide to
testify today objection your honor all
right that's beyond the scope of what we
just talked about
all right i'll sustain the objection
thank you miss moth uh we have nothing
further at this time we greatly
appreciate your taking the time
to testify any cross examination